[music]
here in
many ways I
started herbs, of
course, we are not better than at home, but
you can hurry slowly you see us, you can
say good conditions in terms of the fact that
they are days on the platform with a child or
give you food, the
toilet seemed to be quietly
[music]
b2 babaha it was  at five in the morning for one
there for a couple of minutes 6 we jumped up and
we can see everything around it, so everyone
saw the glow in different places
around the district
husband said it was a war passing
[music]
happy ours to the neighboring house and our
area was very heavily bombed  and that's why we
had to leave
very scared we get home 1
tram depot we have right now the
first ones will be the tram depot I
just had to have
my life
[music]